you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between Gary Kasparov playing on the
white end against layout sport ish this
was from the Knicks ik tournament of
1983 this tournament consisted of 15
players a few former world champions
competing mikhail tall Tigran Petrosian
and Boris Spassky so let's dive into
this round for a game and see what makes
it one of the greats
Kasparov opening with d4 we have a
Queen's Indian defense and this little
move a3 designed to preserve the knight
and ultimately throw a punch at the
Queen Bishop may sound odd but there is
this idea to play d5 and then e for next
and the bishop is effectively biting on
a rock
so black sees this playing d5 himself C
takes black is recapturing with a
peacekeeping open the long diagonal
White has a central majority but cannot
yet set it into motion that would drop
upon
Knight takes B takes white and starts a
check
ultimately the bishop will be best
placed on d3 but why not throw in this
check and see if you can provoke a poor
move there's only one good reply here
and it's the game move c6 doing
otherwise a night block allows light to
pounce and if the bishop goes to c6
white can say AHA you're C pawn can't
move to c5 so easily you'll have to
waste some time so c6 Bishop d3 and only
then c5 so in the end we basically have
a position that we would have had if the
bishop went to d3 straight away castles
knight c6 for the moment this diagonal
is not opened but yeah his eyes will be
opened up soon enough Queen d2 group to
d1 the Queen gets out of the line of
fire and here we go y can go forward
with E for setting the central majority
into motion or another option
Bob tries c-form this is white is
welcome to a hanging pawn structure with
this advance that's what we have soon
enough
and right now white is just one moment
away
from having this bishop see the heart of
the kingside structure directly I want
to draw some attention to this because
if you're playing on the black side you
may already be saying to yourself you
know what that Bishop on b2 is going to
be really strong maybe I should look to
offset him by playing Bishop to f6 this
would be faulty let's see why if Bishop
to f6 white would have d5 Bishop takes
Bishop loses a piece to pawn takes
Knight and if Knight to e5 White has
this little tactic capturing on h7 and
then recapturing White's up upon so in
short you cannot look to negate the
Bishop on b2 with Bishop to f6 at this
moment in the game C takes d4 eat aches
and light has now the hanging pawn
structure
a-five clears the way
the bishops way and major pieces way c4
is now a focal point struck at multiple
times three times only defended twice
white ignores this though pressing
forward with d5 opening this guy's eyes
up and you know you can't take on c4
there's a some issue with that in the
game we had e takes d5 taking on c4
allows Queen 2e for provoking g6 and
then Queen to e5 looking for mate light
is in the driver's seat from here
so in the game it was it takes d5 C
takes d5
Bishop takes d5 and now the first of two
Bishop sacrifices snipping on h7 not a
true sacrifice as you are getting that
material right back
rook takes Bishop
King to g8 and yeah that's sensible
because you're just on a completely open
dog and I'll multiple checks are in the
air
all right the four different checks five
different ones not that Queen to c2 is
the greatest you get the idea the King
does better on g8 playing to c2 allows
Queen to e5 and this is a big issue for
black threatening mate Queen to h5 ideas
so King do it King to g8 is played and
now we have the second of two sacrifices
Bishop takes g7 a double bishop sac and
King to G's can takes bishop of course
what was interesting to me is learning
that Kasparov did not consider Bishop
takes GC g7 as a sacrifice he viewed it
as an exchange of pieces he saw the g7
pawn in other words as extremely
valuable to black without it the king
the black king is forever without a home
with the Queen still on the board you
can be sure that the black King will be
in trouble
moreover if we consider
after this sacrifice the night positions
whose night stands better it's clearly
White's night who next placed into e5
the night is far away from the action
that's what we have Knight to e5 paving
the way for potentially rook d7 move and
also Queen to g4
recon recon f2 da displayed challenging
the rook and opening up a new square for
the king queen g4 King f8 white is now
inching a little bit closer to the king
threatening made on f7
black defends with f6 defending with
Bishop to d6 gives up the f6 square to
the Queen white would be able to inch
one step closer multiple ideas in mind
Queen to h8 Knight to g6 with Queen to
h8 ideas and if Bishop takes Knight
how are you defending the main threat
Queen 2h a or even the idea of swinging
the rook in 2h a you're not best is to
give up your Queen at that point so
Bishop to d6 was not played f6 Knight to
d7 follows this knight must be captured
and is with rook takes Knight if the
King tries to run he is going to run
into some serious trouble going towards
the center and that's a nice little mate
so he's intolerable is the short story
rook takes Knight rook takes rook and
black says can we have a queen exchange
White says no way your King is much more
weak Queen h7
rip to c7 and now we have a very
important moment in the game actually
and I'll throw a little pop quiz to you
what would you play as white in this
position if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video like to move what would you do
okay white plays the move Queen to h8
this is an extremely important move
because you know if you want to keep
this rook around and play into d3
instead there's a big issue with this
move okay what's the issue
here's another pop quiz if you'd like
what would black do if you played the
move rook to d3 here
okay black would have this wonderful
tactic of capturing on f2
it's impressive move if rook takes Queen
that's going to run into me
the tides turn and Queen after a rip to
d3 Queen TAFE the Queen takes f2 if the
King takes now we have this check and
then rook takes Queen and black is out
of the woods the game continues
but this imbalance but yeah without the
Queen's on the board blacks king isn't
shaking so much so you have to
anticipate this little tactical shot and
first play Queen to h8 get the Queen out
of the line of fire and only then player
rook to d3 so it's easy to get caught up
into this attack attack attack which is
what White has been doing since move
what seems like move 17 move 19 yeah you
have to anticipate your opponent's
threats there and there was a that was
that would have been a really that would
have been a cold shower
for sure following up we have Knight to
c4
productive d1 getting the last piece
involved and Knight to e5 and black
should not be thinking about winning
material this is not working going here
runs into mate going here will be
running into mate soon enough
to block in a few different ways but who
cares rook to d8 next is mate and so
what else if here you could give checks
okay
in short this night should not be
looking to grant material Knight to e5
hoping to secure some key squares around
the King hoping to defend little punches
thrown but now this game finishes up
very nicely with a little King walk to
finish queen h7 dropping back to these
squares results into that same tactical
sequence I already highlighted so the
game of King e6 Queen g8 King f5 g4 if
Knight takes pawn rook F 3 and then
Queen takes Knight leading to mate
eventually
here here matin - right around the
corner
the game move King to f4
rook to d4 King to f3 and one last move
Queen to b3 and the black King has had
enough black throwing in the towel at
this point no good move here if queen
block we would have check check and
checkmate but that's as far as it went a
nice little King walk here to end double
bishops sack a little King walk to end
this one and yeah a really nice finish
for sure very very direct play so as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
and I'll catch you soon that's all for
now take care bye
you